you got to keep going
keep going keep going
at this school in nova scotia students
learn from indigenous elders and
teachers in their community
how many understood
what i said
i did
what did i say and across the country in
this alberta public school how many of
you cut wood to stay warm in the winter
culture traditions and history are woven
throughout the day what's that bird
called what's the name of that bird but
without a national mandatory curriculum
these teachings and experiences don't
exist in all schools despite the need
and calls for it education is the key to
change education is the only way to
create real long-term sustainable change
it was the first it was
the only one of its kind
that was always the vision for pauline's
shirt she's an elder now and still
leading the way changing how children
are taught in school about indigenous
people in canada all of these are
graduated we need to educate people what
happened truly
like so many indigenous children pauline
her sisters and cousins were taken to a
residential school in alberta
pauline was eight years old
they brought us in
and the first thing they did was cut our
hair and to us
our hair is our power they put some
kerosene on our hair
kerosene can you imagine
schools where students were forced to
assimilate abused for their culture and
for speaking their language we weren't
allowed to speak our language we were
told hey this is who you're going to be
you're going to be like you know
to assimilate us say
despite what she faced emotionally and
physically her spirit never dimmed
decades later as a parent her daughters
and sons were attending public school in
toronto and suffering terrible racism
she says her son clayton would come home
from school bloodied
you know he was being bullied because he
had long hair and and you know he was
the only conditional being there they
were really just
horrible horrible horrible they made
them feel ashamed they made them feel
you know they were ill-treated
so in 1976 she started the first
indigenous school in toronto with her
late husband vern harper i started in
the living room and i said this is the
start of our school we're going to have
our own school
anybody heard of nana bazooka
they called it kapapamachaque
wandering spirit school a good life for
my children
a better life for my children that they
could they don't have to come home
crying or you know being but with racist
attitudes
at the time vern described the school in
a national film board documentary this
is a reason why it's so important that
we see our history through our
interpretation
pauline took us back to her former home
in an east toronto neighborhood this is
where i started wandering spirit it is a
four bedroom apartment the key
they determined what an authentic
indigenous education looked like this
was our school our curriculum was our
way of life
we took them to places
uh you know land-based teaching we took
them to ceremonies we took them to sweat
lodges we started something in here
something that will go on forever
pauline's legacy continues in 18 year
old ella laform she was one of the first
high school graduates from wandering
spirit
the school is now jk to grade 12 and
housed in a much bigger building in
toronto's east end
ella started her education in a
mainstream public school she remembers
being just 10 years old having teachers
call on her to explain indigenous
culture and history to the class what
did that feel like i was like being put
on the spot for like things i didn't
know about and then also if i what like
if i didn't tell them anything it was
almost like i was really disappointing
them and i felt like almost guilty like
i wasn't like i should have been
speaking about my culture even though i
knew i couldn't because i didn't even
know what they were talking about do you
think the teachers had the right
resources with what they were teaching
we should just throw out all the
textbooks history textbooks because it
like makes me kind of upset they only
really talk about like the falling or
the
like eradication of indigenous people
and they only talk about us in past
tense as if we aren't here anymore we
are like successful people who do
successful things the kids are fine it's
the adults who can't handle it
charlene bearhead is a long-time
educator and advocate denial is a big
issue
i think that many canadians and many
non-indigenous leaders have a really
hard time wrapping their heads around
the fact and accepting that the history
that we've learned in our education
systems across this country
for
150 years has been inaccurate
has been biased
education falls under the provinces and
territories so despite calls from the
truth and reconciliation commission
there is still no mandatory curriculum
what message does it send to indigenous
people if indigenous education is not
mandated in canada the message that it
gives is
indigenous people are not important
indigenous knowledge is not valid
knowledge it's not important to
acknowledge the atrocities that have
been perpetrated on indigenous people
even in the last year there were
incidents of public school students in
different parts of the country being
asked to describe the advantages or
benefits of residential schools there
are still definitely you know bias and
racist resources that are kicking around
they're not as easy to find which is a
good thing we
have been
sort of trained to believe that if
something's in writing it must be true
and students see that it's so much
harder to
to get people to unlearn things what's
also key is who is teaching it's
everything we do is for the children and
how they are doing it indigenous people
must be involved do we still have our
cultures
and resources must be authentic and
accurate i think there are many people
who are just not comfortable and they're
afraid to do something wrong
but it's about relationship and it's
about taking those risks and it's about
learning you know and
and as educators it's okay for us to
admit that we don't know all of this
because we weren't educated in this way
i had many friends growing up that were
indigenous that i had no idea
what their ancestors went through
janet botterill teaches at glen allen
elementary in edmonton she's not
indigenous and says she never learned
about the treatment and genocide of
indigenous peoples until she took a
required teaching course in university
and that's where i first heard the term
residential school and that's where i
thought okay
what don't i know what can i know and
how can i make sure that i help the
community and make sure this never
happens again
oh look at this there's
berries right here
we're here today in the forest
because this is
our university thank you thank you
committed to change education at this
school is developed entirely through
partnerships i want to teach you and
with knowledge from indigenous leaders
give yourself a round of applause
including elder wilson you see these
trees up here
those ones are to keep you warm make a
fire for you he's part of the lessons
here
[Music]
sharing stories and underscoring the
importance of protecting nature and it's
nice and bright right central to
indigenous ways of life
i thank you for sharing and being here
today and being a part of this lesson
and continuing to build your knowledge
with an open heart
most of the students here are not
indigenous they're taught about the
history of residential schools in canada
i think it's sad because they weren't
even allowed to speak their own language
something that is still not consistent
across the country in the video too you
heard the man at the beginning he said
going to school the first day of this of
school was the hardest day of his life
now should coming to school be the
hardest day of your life
it should not
we'll give you a few minutes if you want
to write or draw
out jeremy albert shares his cree
language
janet says one of the biggest challenges
is that teachers don't know where to
start and that they're afraid of making
mistakes a lot of people see it as you
know what this is just a subject that i
need to teach at this time and that's
how it is and it's by itself but really
you can entertwine intertwine
indigenous education into everything
that you do all of your daily practices
that's why in her school teachers and
school administrators meet regularly
with elders to go over and refine their
programming our students are the ones
who are going to educate their parents
their friends other people in the
community
lynda isadora sees the change in her
students
have a nice day
she's an elementary teacher in wamacook
nova scotia on cape breton island
hi honey
the school is part of the migma
ogamatinue school district do you
remember the other day we were
discussing about the importance of
having black ash and white desk 20 years
ago only 30 percent of students
graduated high school across the
district now it's over 90 percent
remember
school administrators say that
remarkable success is due to the
jurisdiction and autonomy that the migma
community has over how it teaches they
know more about their culture while
they're in this community so they feel
connected does anybody know what a black
ass looks like migma language and
culture are part of everything they do
at this school
so the next page is
how do trees make their food remember we
discussed that to the emphasis on
outdoor place based education
platinum this tree is a commitment to
migamo culture our history and the
future as a child linda attended a
public school in a nearby community
where racism and ignorance were rampant
i remember as a young girl i'm like what
is it that makes me
so ugly so
bad that makes me stick out people would
call me names that was the kind of thing
that was going through my head but you
could feel almost like a vibe of some of
the teachers
linda knows the public school system
across the country has work to do
real and lasting change starts with
education she's now helping create a
guide for teachers to use in public
schools
i don't want any of the kids i know now
to go through what i had to go through
but i also want them to have pride of
who they are pride is what ella says
being a wandering spirit graduate gave
her
she's now in her first year in
university studying psychology and
advocating for indigenous peoples and
for better education
and you should tell people that like
you're indigenous and you're still here
you should be proud of who you are
pauline is in her 80s now but she's not
stopping anytime soon
beautiful
just gorgeous
[Music]
there's sweet grass there
outside the apartment where she launched
that first school all those years ago a
memorial her son helped create to
remember the residential school
survivors
the spirit of mutual healing our canoe
is in honor of all those who are
affected by this experience
pauline's work represents the future too
in the educational system we have to
accept me as a human being accept
yourself i'll accept you as a human
being that education has the power to
change makes me feel proud really feel
proud that i am that i have done my work
but it's not finished
[Music]